In this video we'll try to make
predictions for the 2012-2013
season.
We'll need to load our test set
because our training set only
included data from 1980 up
until the 2011-2012 season.
So let's call it NBA_test.
And we'll read it in
the same way as always,
read.csv("NBA_test.csv").
All right, so now let's try
to predict using our model
that we made in the previous
video, how many points we'll
see in 2012-2013 season.
Let's call this
PointsPrediction.
And so we use the
predict command here.
And we give it the previous
model that we made.
We'll give it
PointsReg4, because that
was the model we determined
at the end to be the best one.
And the new data
which is NBA_test.
OK, so now that we have our
prediction, how good is it?
We can compute the out
of sample r-squared.
This is a measurement
of how well
the model predicts on test data.
The r squared value we
had before from our model,
the 0.8991, you might
remember, is the measure
of an in-sample
r-squared, which is
how well the model
fits the training data.
But to get a measure of the
predictions goodness of fit,
we need to calculate the
out of sample r-squared.
So let's do that here.
We need to compute the
sum of squared errors.
And so this here is just the
sum of the predicted amount
minus the actual amount of
points squared and summed.
And we need the total
sums of squares,
which is just the sum of
the average number of points
minus the test actual
number of points.
So the r-squared here
then is calculated
as usual, 1 minus the sum
of squared errors divided
by total sums of squares.
And we see that we have an
r squared value of 0.8127.
We can also calculate the root
mean square error the same way
as before, root
mean squared error
is going to be the square root
of the sum of squared errors
divided by n, which is the
number of rows in our test data
set.
OK and the root mean squared
error here is 196.37.
So it's a little bit
higher than before.
But it's not too bad.
We're making an average
error of about 196 points.
We'll stop here for now.
Good luck with the homework.